un salon de coiffure une boulangerie et
un café leur point commun c'est d'avoir
été achetée par claude deltor ex chef
d'entreprise à la retraite son sens des
affaires s'est mué en philanthropie
aujourd'hui on sous les jeunes c'est
très difficile de s'installer parce
qu'en fait tu dis rien aux normes donc
pour moi ça semble évident de le
commerce il faut amener aider à mettre
aux normes pour qu'un jeune quelqu'un
s'installe à moindre coût son premier
investissement claude la réaliser il y a
deux ans en acquérant cette bâtisse en
très mauvais état pour y installer des
boulangers
on a travaillé main dans la main avec
lui pour refaire une belle boutique pour
s'installer là voilà est aujourd'hui bas
on est très heureux d'être ici on a une
bonne clientèle on travaille bien
haru commune de trois mille huit cents
habitants ce sont une vingtaine de
commerces qui ont fermé leurs portes en
quelques décennies la commune ne peut
pas investir dans tous les commerces ne
peut acheter que les murs dès l'instant
que ce n'est pas le dernier commerce
d'avoir quelqu'un qui est vraiment qui
aime son village c'est une chance
l'homme que l'on dit providentiel est un
enfant du pays sa famille il vit depuis
cinq générations
mon père venait d'acquis et mma copa de
l'ancien propriétaire ici claude a
racheté les murs du salon pour faciliter
la vente du fonds de commerce quand la
coiffeuse décidera de partir plutôt que
d'avoir un investissement lourd murs et
fonds là du coup ça permet de
s'installer il ya l'habitation dessus ou
pas d'ailleurs lui ça peut lui permettre
de louer à quelqu'un d'autre en eau et
puis dépendamment le bas avec le
commerce c'est sympa quoi
mon argent je mets là et puis si tout
simplement pour faire profiter la
commune le philanthrope a encore plein
d'autres projets en tête mais il espère
surtout avoir fait des émules
[Musique]